a four-year-old girl from central New
Jersey is a latest child confirmed to
have died from the flu virus health
officials say she did not get the flu
shot and she died in December dr. Tara
Narula visited the largest health care
provider in New York state to see its
new approach to fighting the flu Tara
good morning good morning Gail northwell
health treats millions of patients each
year it is one of the largest health
systems in the country and now it's
implementing a one-of-a-kind bio
surveillance system to proactively
combat this historic deadly influenza
outbreak it's all hands on deck at the
emergency operations unit at northwell
health on Long Island the Suffolk County
is being hit hardest with this
cutting-edge flu surveillance system
they can take in information from all
their hospitals in almost real-time
bypassing the typical one to two week
time lag on information from state and
federal health officials you'll see this
is up to yesterday so you're within 24
hours as vice president of emergency
management mary mahoney says the system
is a game-changer and what types of
resources might you send to an area that
you see a spike things like do we have
enough mass to protect our patients and
our families and our staff the large
number of this population is pediatric
population do we have the appropriate
doses of Tamiflu for them if we're going
to be treating them with Tamiflu this
season at least 39 children have died
from flu related complications in at
least 25 states and that number is
expected to rise kids are vulnerable
because of their immune system they're
young they haven't been exposed to this
before so their body attacks them full
on dr. Eric goddess Minh is director of
the intensive care unit at Northshore
University Hospital at what point does
somebody say I should get to an
emergency room you're having problems
breathing becoming lethargic and popping
up yellow green then it's time to get to
the emergency room north wells
biosurveillance unit could become a
model for other hospital systems in full
disclosure I'm employed by north well
they say their information could help
public health officials hone in on zip
codes and more specific locations for
targeted outreach it could also be used
to track and respond to other infectious
disease outbreaks in the future
Kaira thank you it sounds like a lot of
these hospital systems who are
overwhelmed there's a lot of sick people
coming in absolutely so something like
this could be beneficial to other
Hospital networks in the country good
information thank you